[Musica]
[Applauso]
in video al vostro coraggio siete di
grande ispirazione
vorrei avere la forza di farlo anche io
questi sono alcuni dei commenti che io e
chiara riceviamo ogni volta che postiamo
una nostra foto sui social
e a chi non conosce chi non ci conosce e
sorgerà spontanea una domanda di quale
eroiche gesta ci saremmo mai rese
protagoniste abbiamo militato nelle
diete generosa va siamo dalle reporter
di guerra dalla striscia di gaza
niente di tutto questo semplicemente
siamo due donne grasse che vivono
liberamente il proprio corpo e nello
specifico siamo due attiviste per la fat
acceptance un movimento che nasce dalla
seconda ondata femminista degli anni 70
ed è l'antenato dalla body positivity
quest'ultima ha spopolato
ultimamente nella maggior parte dei
media dedicati ad un pubblico
prettamente femminile grazie a una
retorica legata all'autostima alla marea
se stesse ad accettare il proprio corpo
ma la fat acceptance non è così
palatabile perché denuncia le
discriminazioni che subiscono le persone
grasse nello specifico la grasso fobia
quest'ultima parola si sente nominare
ancora meno spesso perché viene
difficile
percepire le persone grasse come vittime
perché siamo ritenute responsabili della
nostra stessa condizione
io e chiara siamo cresciute viviamo in
sardegna una terra nota come meta estiva
famosa per le sue bianche spiagge
sabbiose incastrate nel granito rosa è
lambita da acque turchesi
ma noi per anni in quelle torri destati
di buffy sudati e sotto testa su dati ci
siamo convinte che andare al mare o
fosse un abitudine volgare
evitavamo di andare per l'appunto al
mare vestivamo di nero ascoltavamo
canzoni tristi rifuggiva mo quegli
orribili salubri raggi solari per citare
maga magò
ovviamente la verità era che eravamo a
disagio con il nostro corpo e
terrorizzate all'idea di lasciarlo alla
mercè di un giudizio che conoscevamo già
molto bene ma nel momento in cui abbiamo
deciso di rivendicare lo spazio che
occupiamo nel mondo e la parola grassa
come un aggettivo neutro senza alcuna
accezione negativa
la nostra vita è cambiata è
improvvisamente si siano trasformate
contemporaneamente in eroina e ma anche
nel cattivo esempio da additare al
pubblico ludibrio
eroi che perché ci vuole coraggio a
mostrare un corpo come il nostro che è
considerato un inestetismo da debellare
da coprire è da correggere è anche un
nemico pubblico perché questo nostro
vivere in questo modo il nostro corpo
potrebbe incoraggiare altre persone a
fare la stessa cosa e cosa potrebbe
succedere che queste creature che vivono
negli abissi della vergogna potrebbero
evolversi strisciare verso la terraferma
e trasformarsi in qualcosa di
imprevedibile come delle persone a tutto
tondo che non somigliano minimamente
alla rappresentazione che ne viene fatta
delle persone grasse sulla televisione
al cinema e nelle serie tv
una donna magra che è posta una foto
mentre mangia dei carboidrati complessi
viene celebrata perché non è
ossessionata dalla dieta perché è stata
benedetta da un metabolismo più veloce
di usain bolt ma se si disattendono le
aspettative
eh
si smette si scardina lo stereotipo
della donna grassa
infelice insoddisfatta e patetica ci si
trasforma in promotrici dell'obesità che
poi me la immagino la vita dalla
promotrice dell'obesità come quella
delle network marketer che ti vendono i
frullati per dimagrire come una ghiotta
occasione di guadagno una straordinaria
opportunità di lavoro però al contrario
in quanto donne grasse siamo considerate
meno valide come donne quindi ci si
aspetta che la vergogna sia il nostro
habitat il luogo in cui osservare alla
nostra specie in cui dobbiamo essere
studiate
perché il nostro corpo è
considerato la trasposizione delle
nostre cattive abitudini dalla nostra
negligenza del nostro indulgere nel cibo
spazzatura ma breaking news la persone
grasse sono sempre esistite
a testimonianza di questo c'è la venere
di b lendorf una statua che rappresenta
una donna grassa è che risale al al
paleolitico
ora c'è qualcosa che non ci hanno detto
dalla preistoria per caso i poteri forti
ci hanno nascosto i fossili dell'happy
meal
sono passati diversi anni da quando il
grasso era considerato un simbolo di
fertilità è una caratteristica tipica
dei ceti più alti esattamente un secolo
e mezzo e
ad essere responsabili del processo
culturale che ha portato il grasso ad
essere disprezzato ci sono
contribuiscono il classismo il
colonialismo la tratta transatlantica
degli schiavi e il suprematismo bianco
ora
per parlare dell'iter storico che ha
portato a questa situazione
questo intervento dovrebbe avere più o
meno la durata della trilogia della
depressione di lars von trier
ma
perché le persone grasse sono coraggiose
e nello specifico perché io e chiara lo
siamo dal momento che sono partita dalla
nostra esperienza
sebbene i commenti che ho citato in
apertura siano indubbiamente mossi da
buone intenzioni
il sottotesto rimane il fatto che
dobbiamo essere coraggiosi per mostrare
questo scopo dovremmo vergognarci e
infatti ci viene spontaneo domandarsi ma
e ammirazione per la nostra autostima o
stupore perché non ci facciamo
terribilmente schifo
in realtà
l'autostima ha poco a che fare con tutto
questo perché noi non pensiamo di essere
le donne più avvenenti che abbiano mai
calpestato il suolo terrestre e non
viviamo neanche nelle statica
contemplazione del nostro riflesso allo
specchio
infatti sono altre le motivazioni a
muoverci ovvero l'idea che non dovrebbe
esistere uno standard da perseguire
quando si parla di corpi e che ogni
corpo sia valido a prescindere dal suo
peso dal suo stato di salute dalla sua
abilità dalla sua identità di genere e
dalla sua razza
quindi
ci viene anche da dire che
in ogni caso l'autostima non cambierebbe
mai la nostra condizione nella società
perché è appunto il modo in cui la
navighiamo vi faccio un esempio
immaginiamo questa conversazione
guardi signorina lei non rappresenta i
valori del brand che
traduzione non è di bella presenza lega
grassa risposta ma guardi mi dia
l'occasione di dire che mi amo non so se
abbiamo avuto modo di discuterne io mi
amo da morire andiamo di brutto quindi
dovrebbe rivedere le sue decisioni
e insensato giusto e insensato perché
stiamo parlando di uno stigma sistemico
la grasso fobie esiste sia una
dimensione intrapersonale ovvero il modo
in cui noi viviamo il nostro corpo sia
in una dimensione sistemica ovvero nel
nostro modo di muoversi all'interno
dell'ambiente di lavoro e determina
anche pregiudizi in ambiente medico
anche accessibilità in luoghi pubblici
per le persone con un corpo più grasso
quindi anche se vivessimo nel culto del
nostro corpo de di noi stesse manco
fossimo kanye west non cambierebbe la
situazione
però bisogna dire che effettivamente
siamo coraggiose ma non perché mese
mostriamo il nostro corpo o esistiamo in
modi inaspettati lo siamo perché sebbene
veniamo considerato il prima di un dopo
che suona come un e vissero felici e
contenti noi decidiamo di vivere
liberamente la nostra vita lo siamo
perché rivendichiamo la parola
considerata l'insulto per eccellenza
tanto che vengono utilizzati un sacco di
giri di parole del femi smi per evitare
di pronunciarla come robusta
formosa
grassottella paffuta bella di faccia ma
anche mi è capitato ben distribuita
manco fossi un luminoso attico a milano
dalla moderna distribuzione degli
interni lo siamo perché
siamo allo stesso tempo
nascoste in piena vista
è anche facile obiettivi invisibili
perché considerate donne non valide di
attenzione quanto meno quella maschile
ma anche
continuamente oggetto di giudizio
sul vocabolario la definizione di
coraggio è qualità d'animo che permette
di
andare oltre
un ostacolo un pericolo ma il nostro
corpo non è un ostacolo e non è neanche
un pericolo è nessun corpo non normato
lo è
ora io spero in questi pochi minuti che
con le mie parole io sia riuscito a
dargli una vaga idea di cosa sia la
grasso fobia e di aver aperto una
piccola crepa nelle convinzioni nei
pregiudizi che avete nei confronti dei
corpi è che quando uscirete da di qui
comincerete a
smantellare alla vostra grasso fobie
viene eretta nella nostra lotta ma allo
stesso tempo vorrei che queste parole
fossero una sorta di bat segnale che io
immagino come un grande sedere nel cielo
tra l'altro per tutte quelle persone che
sono grasse voglio che sappiano che il
loro momento di smettere di odiarsi di
disprezzarsi di vergognarsi
anche mettere quel vestito che si diceva
che non ci potevamo permettere o per
cercare di passare inosservati abbiamo
evitato io per esempio stasera ho fatto
esattamente il contrario questo è il
vostro momento dovete vivere la vostra
vita qui e oggi e siete liberi e libere
di prendere tutto lo spazio che volete
grazie
[Applauso]
governo
[Musica]